bonsoir à tous c'est ça vous regarde
ravi de vous retrouver au sommaire ce
soir on va prendre le temps de débriefer
ces nouvelles auditions de la commission
denquête deux anciennes ministres de la
santé de doctrine opposés sur le stock
de masques et deux versions du principe
de précaution
roselyne bachelot marisol touraine qu at
on appris ce soir
la réponse de nos invités dans un
instant on parlera aussi de cette
saignée dans l'aéronautique 7500 postes
supprimés air france 15000 airbus dont
5000 en france la crise du coc vider la
plus violente de l'histoire de
l'aviation que peu l'état actionnaire
décryptage à suivre enfin dans ma
journée à l'assemblée thomas des prêts
elle nous parlera de l'attrait des
territoires on devait en parler hier on
en parle finalement ce soir 20 députés
sur 22 c'est beaucoup élu aux
municipales qui ont choisi de quitter le
palais bourbon alors le travail des
parlementaires serez témoin d'
intéressant cab en réponse à la fin de
cette émission voilà pour le programme
est axé vers pour réagir c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
regarder ce sourire une pointe de
satisfaction
pas de triomphalisme ce sourire elle n'a
pas tué le masque et même s'il n'aura
duré que quelques secondes roselyne
bachelot très sobre tout de noir vêtu
face aux députés de la commission d'
enquête sur la crise sanitaire qui a
fini par ne plus pouvoir retenir c est
ce que ministre c'est être au courant de
tout oui oui c'est être au courant de
tout et si on n'est pas au courant de
quelque chose s'arranger pour le savoir
et voilà un coup de griffe direct un
tacle à l'ayguade agnès buzyn qui a
expliqué hier qu'elle n'était pas au
courant de la faune du stock stratégique
de masque on va en parler ce soir avec
vous martin blachier bonsoir vous êtes
médecin épidémiologiste directeur de la
société de conseil public health
expertise en face de vous julia borowicz
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous députés
la république en marche de la loire
vice-président de cette commission
denquête vous ne suivez vous suivez tout
et vous ne ratez rien tout comme boris
ballot bonsoir et bienvenue à député
socialiste des landes alors on va
commencer par plutôt bourreuse une
bachelot mais d'abord un principe qui a
beaucoup inspiré stéphane blakowski ce
soir le principe de précaution qui
figure d'ailleurs dans notre
constitution si j'ai bien compris tout
de suite
[Musique]
bon sans myriam bonsoir stéphane si j'ai
bien compris très bien si j'ai bien
compris c'est vraiment pas le moment de
critiquer le principe de précaution en
ce moment je voyais des sondages qui
sont sortis au mois de mai trois quarts
des français sont favorables à ce
principe alors si on reprend la
formulation de la question
quand on demande aux français si en
matière de risques il est normal de
prendre toutes les précautions
même lorsque les experts ont des doutes
et bien 73,5 % répondent oui donc ça
veut dire que dès qu'un groupe d'experts
alerte le gouvernement sur un sujet qui
présentent un risque est bien les
françaises sont d'accord pour qu'on
prenne toutes les précautions
nécessaires pour qu'on puisse être
protégé
évidemment c'est parce que le coroner
virus est passé par là ah oui mais
justement le coran d'un virus parlons-en
parce que s'il ya bien un truc qu'on a
appris pendant les de l'épidémie
coronavirus et que les experts ne sont
jamais d'accord entre eux comment voulez
vous fondez une décision sur les experts
puisque dès qu'un expert dit un truc et
ben ya un autre expert qui dit
exactement le contraire avait remarqué
au départ le président macron pensé que
ça serait plus simple de faire un
conseil scientifique et puis wood
d'appliquer les décisions puis
finalement il a repris la main il a
refait de la politique s'est affranchi
du principe de précaution pourtant
inscrit dans la constitution
alors là on en a on atteint les limites
de mes compétences on les atteint très
vite à d'ailleurs parce que je suis pas
juriste mais quand le congrès a voté en
2005 ce principe de précaution dont il a
inscrit dans la constitution
en fait ça visait les dommages
irréversibles susceptibles d'être causés
à l'environnement donc est ce que la
santé c'est de l'environnement ce pas
évident sk des jurisprudences j'en sais
rien bon alors tout cas là c'est assez
révélateur puisque le problème du
principe de précaution c'est que depuis
qu'il est inscrit dans la constitution
on a comme une tendance à l'appliquer à
peu près à tous les sujets et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que jacques attali redoutait je
ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais
en 2007 nicolas sarkozy lui avait confié
une mission pour libérer la croissance
française libérer la croissance et donc
la première proposition d'attali cedh
est justement de supprimer ce principe
de précaution qui faisait tant de mal à
la croissance en écoute
ce principe est suicidaire il est
mauvais il ne protège pas
l'environnement
il conduit tout naturellement être
appliquée bien au delà de son cercle de
définition bien au delà parce que chacun
veut se protéger et en voulant se
protéger de l'applicateur et à travers
moi je me souviens que le rapporteur de
cette commission attali s'appelait
emmanuel macron
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il est contre
ce principe bah ça suggère en tout cas
qu'il n'a pas toujours été pour le
principe de précaution mais c'est pas le
seul un bruno le maire il était candidat
à la primaire de la droite dans son
programme pour la france dont je vous
propose de regarder si la couverture
magnifique mille pages de programmes et
ben il proposait à la page 575 de
supprimer ce principe de précaution pour
le remplacer par un principe
d'innovation encore plus récemment les
républicains qui ne sont pas là ce soir
mais en 2018 proposait de supprimer le
principe de précaution dans la
constitution
et puis finalement ça n'a pas été adopté
par la majorité des manuels macron et
encore une fois je le redis l'épidémie a
changé la donne bah oui exactement
d'ailleurs hier par la commission
denquête on voit que ça c'est presque ce
qu'est ce que cette question-là la
précaution est un peu sur toutes les
lèvres ou moins dans tous les esprits on
disait agnès buzyn mais enfin mais
pourquoi on n'aurait pas pris les
précautions pourquoi n'y a pas des
stocks de médicaments nécessaires pour
les intubations comment se fait-il que
je n'y ai pas pensé à ça donc autant
nier ce faisant elle était souvent
embêté pour répondre à certaines
questions autant sur cette question là
elle a pris ça avec un petit sourire
amusé parce que franchement pourquoi
elle a pas pris de précautions en écoute
c'est pas parce qu'aujourd'hui un
problème émergent que la ministre doit
forcément savoir un an avant
quel est le stock d'un produit parmi
cent mille gers et refaire l'histoire de
personne ne peut demander ça une
ministre peut être qu'un jour on aura
besoin d'un produit x je sais pas quel
antibiotiques sera utile pour une
bactérie multirésistante on peut pas
demander à la ministre un an avant de
savoir que ce stock de bach t2
d'antibiotiques exister à quelle dose
enfin donc c'est un peu le problème
évidemment avec le principe de
précaution c'est que on a appris ce
qu'il faudrait prendre un maximum de
précautions dans tous les domaines pour
tendre vers le fameux risque zéro n'est
que le risque zéro agnès un peu besoin
vient nous rappeler que c'est impossible
mais finalement la question c'est est-ce
que cette obsession la de tendre vers le
risque zéro de nous protéger tous les
risques ne finit pas par être nuisible
on est là pour en débattre un petit peu
je crois absolument pas faire un petit
tour de table je suis ensuite on passe
aux auditions de l'après midi je vais me
tourner d'abord vers le médecin que vous
êtes
quand vous entendez à une excuse à dire
au fond on peut pas refaire l'histoire
c'est trop facile comment vous réagissez
voilà je suis tous d'accord est ce
qu'elle vient de dire
ça paraît aberrant de pouvoir prévoir
tous les risques et faire des stocks
surtout en cas d'heures après qu'il
faille faire de la prospective moi je
suis d'accord je veux dire que le
principe de précaution en médecine ça
n'existe pas en médecine ont fait du
bénéfice risque donc on est en
permanence en train de peser n'importe
quel médicament n'a que n'importe quelle
nouveauté un général on refait on
reproche plutôt à la france et à
l'europe d'être aux conservateurs et au
contraire de passer prendre de risques
moi je pense que le principe de
précaution il y en a plutôt trop que pas
assez
en france particulièrement oui oui
surprise parfaite réponse soulève
d'accord julien brevets surtout dans ce
contexte une réponse assez similaires
étant médecin généraliste au 6 mai oui
oui c'est le rapport bénéfice risque
maintenant le principe de précaution il
ya aussi le principe de l'acceptabilité
d'une d'une décision quand j'écoutais
votre votre introduction c'est vrai que
le principe de précaution si vous
écoutez des experts
c'est de rester à la maison en conflit
de mon total pendant encore plus
longtemps que ce qu'on avait prévu
c'est ce que propose le professeur
delfraissy est ce que les français
étaient prêts à l'accepter
je n'en suis pas sûr et après une
acceptabilité il ya un problème
et c'était aussi ça le but du conseil
scientifique d'associer aussi la
dimension sociale éthique humaine
quelque part à la dimension scientifique
juste une dernière chose c'est vrai
qu'on a entendu beaucoup de batailles
d'experts parce qu'on a eu affaire à un
virus particulièrement inconnu jusqu
alors sauf que l'administré niasse busin
part du principe de précaution sur un
éventuel médicament miracle aurait pu
servir au cas d'une maladie une bactérie
résistante mais là on parle des mavs
puisque c'est ça le vrai sujet vous
comprenez cette défense là maurice balle
au bond à dire vrai je la comprends la
comprends assez mal on demande pas la
mise de la santé de compter les ampoules
les masques elle même dans les stocks de
l'état
en revanche dès lors qu'on prépare des
plans qu' il ya des doctrines qui sont
élaborées établi qu'ils disent ben voilà
il faut qu est contenu un certain nombre
d'hypothèses temps de masques tant de
d'antivir autant de dispositifs médicaux
eh bien il faut s'assurer dans la
continuité que ça existe bien évidemment
il y aura toujours des imprévus mais
limiter le risque c'est quand même
anticipé aussi la possibilité de crise
grave sinon c'est ce n'était pas très
rassurant hier ce que nous faisons et
agnès b
c'est que on se dit finalement que
neymar est question sur sommes nous
protège et sur d'autres types de risques
contenu final en deux espèces de de
relativité que qu'elle accordait à toute
espèce de toute espèce de risques alors
on va commencer par roselyne bachelot
s'est-elle audition la dernière édition
vous en sortez à peine messieurs une
audition un peu étrange avait été très
très calme au début mais progressivement
il s'est montré un peu agacé mais elle a
toujours été fidèle à elle même très
politique je rappelle que roselyne
bachelot était ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé de 2007 à 2010
et qu'elle a fait face à face à moult
critiques puisqu'il y avait vous
souvenez vous en 2009 la grippe h1n1
moult critiques car moult tests et moult
masque regarder ou fait qu'empirer par
clément mais je me garderai bien de
donner des leçons à mes successeurs ni
de juger leurs actions dans je connais
la difficulté de leur tâche
je ne suis pas devant vous pour faire
des commentaires ou exprimer des
opinions mais bien pour expliquer la
genèse et la mise en oeuvre de mes
décisions
les procès dont j'ai été l'objet les
moqueries les mises en cause ont été
d'une telle violence et d'une telle
injustice que je peux la limite
comprendre les craintes que cela a
suscité chez certains les craintes
suscitées chez certains de mes de mes
successeurs on s'est dit peut-être qu'à
un certain moment il n'y avait plus il y
avait plus de risque à en faire trop
quand faire passer ce n'est pas au
moment où la pandémie se déclare qu'on
peut se procurer des masques
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'avais
constituer ce stock de 1 milliard de
stacks 2e de masques chirurgicaux 728
milliard de masques ffp2 que j'ai
complété avec 60 millions de masques
un ministre doit être informée il s'agit
pas tous les matins que vous ayez note
qui vous dit
on en est là du stock bien entendu mais
la politique des masques c'est le
ministre qui en décident qu'il me faut
expliquer pourquoi j'ai commandé 94
millions de doses
car étant donné le panier de conneries
que j'entends sur cette affaire je suis
heureuse de donner quelques explications
il ya des choses que je regrette j'en ai
déjà dit une je n'ai pas acheté assez de
vaccins
ça c'est sûr si je veux être raccord
avec ma ligne de prévention maximum j'ai
objectivement pris un risque j'ai
entendu un représentant d'un syndicat de
médecins à dire nous n'avions pas de
masque dans nos cabinets m'enfin des
médecins qui n'ont pas de masque dans
leurs cabinets qui se constitue pas un
stock
nous n'avions pas de blouse m'enfin
pourquoi les médecins ne porte plus de
blues
qu'est ce que c'est que cette dent pays
de pasteur qu'est ce que c'est que cette
médecine
on attend que le préfet ou le directeur
de la rs viennent avec une petite
charrette porter des masques
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays
infantiliser il faut quand même un peu
se prendre en main dans ce pays c'est sa
valse on qu'il faut tirer
voilà elle se lâche elle fini par dire
ce qu'elle pense peut-être au médecin
que vous êtes du limbourg vite pour
rebondir sur cette dernière
cette dernière critique ok elle dit au
fond les médecins et à se débrouiller
eux mêmes
et bien pour le coup la raison today à
la raison parce que finalement on n'a
jamais attendu qu'on nous donne une
directive pour acheter du gel hydro
alcoolique ou du savon dans nos cabinets
des gants ou quoique ce soit d'autres
dont je crois deux choses on a besoin de
tirer mélodies de tirer les conséquences
de tout ça en achetant et en se
procurant les dispositifs les
équipements de protection qu'il faut et
puis nous médecins nous soignants et
puis peut-être plus généralement la
population doit peut-être tiré les
enseignements d'une vraie politique de
santé publique et d'hygiène
on n'a peut-être pas mené depuis un
certain nombre d'années et là c'est pas
du tout une critique politique c'est une
critique de société je crois qu'il faut
qu'on en prenne conscience
martin blachier on est un pays un
infantilisme non mais je penche sur la
question des matchs pendant la crise
élection politique a jugé qu'ils sont
scientifiques l'impact sur l'épidémie de
l'histoire des masques de l'histoire des
tests je pense qu'on pourra la
déterminer à mon avis elle sera minime
qu'est ce qui a été déterminant sur
l'épidémie c'est la décision de confiner
la décision d confiné et le schéma de
déconfinement voilà c'est ça qui compte
savoir alors en dehors des personnels
soignants c'est un sujet complètement à
part pour moi écrire qui et les médecins
qui ont
affronter la crise face aux politiques
ça c'est un autre sujet mais pour le
peuple de manière générale le fait
qu'ils aient pas une masse pendant
confinement ça a pas joué sur l'épidémie
puisque ont été confinés le poids du
confinement est trop fort le poids du
masque compte mais ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que cette commission d'
enquête pour savoir ce qu'il s'est passé
ça veut dire que scientifiquement le
poids de tous ces sujets sur l'épidémie
il est très très faible le fait qu'on
n'ait pas eu de test n'a pas joué
puisqu'on était confiné et de toute
façon la décision de se confiner ces
prises très tôt je pense pas qu'il ya eu
un grand grand retard au contraire on a
été assez rapide on n'aurait pas
confiner la france quand il n'y avait
pas de cas et qu'on n'y avait pas de
malades dans les services ça aurait été
impensable donc franchement qu'on
accable le gouvernement pour trois ans
de fignon public a été extrait le genre
que sont bon marché pour la 7 l'ignoré
mais sur un plan épidémiologique et
scientifique je suis pas sûr que c'est
un impact énorme dans les courbes qu'on
peut voir comment vous réagissez
mais c'est effectivement toutes les
cales encore qu'on n'attend pas des
questions qui qui qui ce qui se pose et
qui justifie une commission denquête
parce qu'on peut pas être indifférent au
fait qu'un certain nombre de
scientifiques considèrent que si nous
avions massifier les tests avant
peut-être aurions pu nous dispenser pas
le cas de duel et confinement est ce que
est ce que est ce que finalement la
communication du gouvernement a été
dicté par l'état des stocks les masques
étaient pas utile quand j'en avais pas
il devenait très utile quand y en avait
est-ce que la possibilité de tester
isolées auraient pu être faits notamment
quand il est le directeur général la
santé qui nous dit quand le ms d'y
tester tester tester ça s'adresse pas la
france et qu'un autre professeur qui me
paraît tout aussi vous essayez pas de
compétences scientifiques tout aussi
qualifiés nous dit exactement l'inversé
évidemment on a besoin d'un peu de
clarté parce que la décision publique
précisément quand on n'est pas un
scientifique
elle est censée être éclairées par des
avis qui parfois sont contradictoires
les uns avec les autres et donc la
question de la confiance à être
importante et cette commission enquête
est là aussi pour risques dit le docteur
blachier enfin moi je crois que je
comprends qu'il parle en tant que
scientifique c'est que la gamme et un
billet enfin un billet se permet un
billet c'est une une orientation
politique dans les questions quand on
suit la commission voit bien que les
questions à la république en marche sont
plutôt sympas elles ont parfois tendance
dans l'exposé des questions à soutenir
par exemple agnès buzyn est fière et
l'opposition a au contraire cherché à la
coincer donc il ya une gare une
exploitation politique
non alors là vraiment je pense pas
qu'ils aient d'animosité dans le ton de
la commission denquête vraiment je pense
que d'ailleurs certains de vos collègues
vous auriez vous vous êtes un peu
tendres parfois et on peut on est sur le
même registre de questions il ya des
questions que j'ai posées mois cet après
midi à marisol touraine était pas non
plus tant ou plus complaisant que celles
que j'ai pu poser que j'ai pu poser hier
agnès buzyn précise pour ceux qui ne
rêvent que ma seule freiner dans la même
famille le parti c'est donc ce que ce
que je veux dire c'est que il ya des
décisions qui ont été prises qui il faut
qu'on réussisse à comprendre les raisons
pour lesquelles en allemagne il ya moins
de du moins de décès qu'en france il y
en a été déterré des réponses
l'organisation des soins on va y venir
parce que c'est la deuxième audition
avec marcel touraine qui apporte des
éléments parfois contradictoires entre
les différents dirigeants
oui justement là-dessus je crois
honnêtement c'est la flagornerie pour
l'exécutif mais je crois que c'est tout
l'intérêt de la commission que la mise
en place de l'exécutif avec uniquement
une commission d' enquête sur un volet
très scientifique avec justement une
volonté d'aller voir ce qui se passe à
l'étranger parce que inéluctablement
j'entends ce qui vient d'être dit mais
il ya toujours une connotation politique
c'est logique c'est normal bon voilà je
vous propose d'avancer je voudrais juste
qu'on veut on voit un sujet de m tazir
parce qu'il replace au fond cette
audition dans son contexte
elle n'a pas voulu se faire de politique
même si elle est en a fait évidemment à
fleurets mouchetés elle n'a pas voulu en
tout cas donner de leçons et surtout pas
au fond s'offrir une vraie revanche
les médias l'ont fait pour elle roselyne
bachelot réhabiliter ces signes et ahmed
taya elle a été en première ligne
il y a dix ans roselyne bachelot alors
ministre de la santé affronte l'épidémie
de la grippe h1n1
à l'époque la france dispose de plus
d'un milliard et demi de masse
en janvier 2010 devant la commission des
affaires sociales à l'assemblée
nationale elle est accusée d'avoir
surévalué le danger on a tous des
provisions considérable de masques
aujourd'hui on n'a pas été foutu de nous
dire les experts justement à quel moment
il fallait les maîtres ne pas les mettre
c'est quand même c'est quand même là
aussi je le regrette c'est un gaspillage
de deniers publics chaque collectivité
s'est équipée de manière parfois
massives
il n'y en a pas qui ne l'ait pas fait
voilà aujourd'hui on l'a fait que qu'est
ce qu'on fait de ces masques
c'est monsieur issa diop qui me dit on
ne sait pas quoi faire de nos masques
jeudi les masques ils sont un stock de
précaution excusez moi si ce mot devient
un gros mot ici ils sont à un stock de
précaution qui est destiné à toutes
sortes de pandémie et ce n'est pas
évidemment au moment où là où une
pandémie par exemple du type h5n1
surviendra qu'il s'agira de constituer
les stocks bien entendu en 2020 la crise
sanitaire du coc u19 est passée par là
l'impréparation du gouvernement et
dénoncer un peu partout les masques sont
introuvables
le couac d'aujourd'hui donne raison à
roselyne bachelot alors depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire kobe 19
c'est une dizaine d'invitations dans les
médias ndash comme bonjour bonjour frère
juan ignacio j'aurais dit des bêtes
martichoux madame bachelot bonjour
bonjour bernard poirette enzymes
bachelot bonjour merci fort de son
expérience au ministère de la santé la
parole de roselyne bachelot est attendue
et forcément on lui pose la question
c'est votre revanche en ce moment j'ai
du mal à considérer cela comme une
revanche parce que qui une revanche
c'est quelque chose de joyeux je ne suis
pas joyeuse mois pour moi la chose est
simple
en tant qu'ancienne ministre de la santé
c'est la stratégie de la protection
maximum qui est la seule bonne qui vous
avait été reproché à l'époque walla
walla roselyne bachelot dit recevoir ces
derniers mois des milliers de messages
sympa pour la remercier d'avoir eu
raison trop tôt
comme on rendrait hommage à une lanceuse
d' alerte
maurice bellot elle avait évidemment le
beau rôle aujourd'hui vous qu'être
socialiste rappelle que vous étiez à
l'elysée et ensuite
et même avant tout le monde at françois
hollande vous étiez vous étiez au
ministère de de nombreuses arnaud
montebourg du redressement productif
mais en achat henin s'était l'opposition
socialiste vous regrettez que votre
famille politique je sois tombé dessus
avec beaucoup d'autres en parlant je
ressens rien j étais je n'y étais pas en
tout cas ce que l'on comprend d'évidence
sais que j'ai une dimension politique à
toute crise sanitaire et que la question
de la compréhension par les françaises
et les français et leurs représentants
des choix qui sont faits est une
nécessité impérieuse et dans la crise du
h1n1 comme dans la crise de la pandémie
aujourd'hui et l'utilité de ces
commission denquête c'est de comprendre
et les malheureusement la réitération
des crises c'est qu'on peut tirer d'une
crise à l'autre
un certain nombre de leçons et c'est
vrai aujourd'hui roselyne bachelot elle
a commencé effectivement disant qu'elle
ne jurerait pas la façon dont a été
gérée la crise actuelle et puis de fait
elle l'a fait elle l'a fait un peu le
mystère cartouches allemand s'est pas
normalisée c'est clair ça éclaire aussi
les travaux de la commission c'est pas
une seule audition que l'on ferme en
fait des dizaines et j'allais dire notre
notre opinion sa fille nous où parfois
on est on est démentie dans ce que l'on
croyait sans surprise voit reprocher à
mme ashton pas en avoir dans l'avoir
trop faible il voit reprocher maintenant
a besoin d' par un havre ac fait en fait
quand on est dans l'opposition on est
toujours d'abord à ce stade il n'y a pas
de reproche on essaie de se faire une
opinion
s'agissant des masques je lis il ya une
communication qui a été erratique et
qu'à laisser penser à beaucoup de gens
qui vivent à un problème son imac pas
forcément son plan épidémiologique moi
je ne suis pas capable de le mecredi
masques ne servait pas et mais elle
exactement
et on s'aperçoit qu'en 2018 il ya la
destruction de 600 millions de masques
avec peu de reconstitution de stocks on
a besoin de commander les ministres
semblent pas du tout au courant du truc
ce qui est quand même important
j'aime bien le courrier en guise et un
prénom béton et à la fin quand on a une
responsabilité politique
et oui on n'est pas sur le même registre
qu'il ya des dépôts de plainte
qu'est ce que vous auriez mieux fait
eric ciotti ya quelques semaines des
aiguilles on aurait mieux dégonfle gérer
gifler bien sur terre si vous aviez t on
d'ailleurs je n'en sais absolument rien
voilà face à des difficultés comme ça je
ne sais pas et je sais ce qu'est les
tensions dans l'appareil d'état parce
que moi j'ai vu d'autres crises de près
notamment s'agissant des attentats j'ai
vu ce qu'était l'état sa mobilisation
aussi les moments de doute de ceux qui
de ceux qui décident qui se demandent
comment le pays va réagir
est ce que les institutions vont tenir à
toutes ces questions là se pose de crise
en guinée en tout cas si ça devait se
reproduire et que nous étions
responsabilités et j'espère qu'on n'en
tireraient un certain nombre de leçons
alors on va aller dans le détail vous
dire ajouter quelque chose juste dire
une chose sur le déconfinement je crois
que la france a été un des premiers pays
en europe à se poser la question et a
travaillé sur le déconfinement je pense
que la france a été assez leader sur ce
sujet là je crois que ça c'est une
séquence qui a été très réussie et moi
j'ai des journalistes à une certitude
est mieux réussie comprendre comment la
france a si bien réussi sa stratégie de
confinement et je pense que le plus dur
c'est maintenant fait c'est petit et pas
avant je pense que plusieurs c'est
maintenant parce qu'il va falloir
trouver exactement la bonne balance
entre la risque de reprise épidémique
est là risque d' anéantissement total de
la société française et là mon avis
c'est là que ça va vraiment joué près de
partie de ceux qui pensent que il y aura
une deuxième vague même si elle est de
moindre ampleur l'un des premiers à
penser je suis rejoint par de plus en
plus de gens je suis pas sûr qu'ils
grondent aujourd'hui qui pense qui a pas
de risque de circulation virale de
risque il existe et maintenant vas
falloir dose et ça ça va être assez
difficile dans les voitures alors on va
aller au fond du dossier qui savait quoi
sur le stock de masques on parle de la
fonte de ce stock fonds ppte stocks
stratégiques
et puis surtout de son état puisque
certains ont l'air de dire qu'ils
étaient périmés voir moisi d'autres
qu'il n'y avait pas de date de
péremption
bonsoir géraldine woessner merci d'être
avec nous derrière votre écran vous êtes
journaliste au point chroniqueuse dans
cette émission et vous avez suivi
attentivement l'audition de marisol
touraine
que faut-il en retenir mais on a
clairement assister à une passe d'armes
avec agnès buzyn qui s'est défendu hier
en répétant que jamais
verser la moindre alerte sur l'état des
stocks de masques chirurgicaux et d'anti
héros périmés qu'elle avait découvert
cette situation à la veille de la crise
alors même que ses services le savez
puisque ils avaient été alertés depuis
depuis 2018 ce qui fait dire d'ailleurs
à l'un des députés mais c'est un pilote
dans l'avion qui dirige
pour marisol touraine c'est clairement
la ministre elle dit avoir payé on sait
qui fait quoi il y a des gens qui
prennent des décisions évidemment une
ministre ne va pas compter les ampoules
mais une ministre elle marque des
orientations
elle prend des arbitrages et elle est
amenée à certains moments à poser des
questions et à regarder sur certains
sujets qui lui sont posées quelle est la
position qu'elle prendre et des
décisions dont elle en aurait prise
marisol touraine celle de ne pas
renouveler le stock de masques ffp2
l'époque par exemple c'était logique il
ya une nouvelle doctrine qui disait que
c'était aux établissements eux mêmes de
son équipe et elle assume donc
parfaitement de ne pas les avoir
renouvelé en revanche son explication
selon les masques chirurgicaux qui ont
cristallisé en quelque sorte la gestion
chaotique de cette crise est beaucoup
moins claire
donc elle dit avoir veillé
personnellement à ce qu'on garde un
niveau élevé mais élevé de de masques
chirurgicaux pour le grand public c'est
ça voila voila proches de ceux milliards
recommandés dans différents rapports
il y avait sept cent vingt millions de
masques quand j'arrivais 750 quand je
suis parti et elle donne le détail des
commandes qu'elle a réalisé oui j'ai
commandé des masques
il y a eu une volonté de toujours aller
le plus loin possible et si nous n'avons
pas encore une fois je me répète mais si
nous n'avons pas dit il faut absolument
pousser les feux c'est parce que on me
disait un il n'y a pas de date de
péremption et de avec 750 millions de
masques
on est quand même par et on n'est pas
dans une situation où on est démuni
label donne des chiffres qui ne vont pas
le stock dormant qu'elle a trouvé en
2012 on comprend qu'elle ne l'a en fait
pas ou quasiment pas renouvelée sans
11 millions de masques ont été commandés
pendant qu'elle était aux affaires elle
s'en explique en répétant plusieurs fois
mais on m'a dit qu'il y avait pas de
date de péremption pour ses masques
comment ont-ils pu se retrouver moisi
dans ce cas inutilisable là pas de
réponse sinon moi vous savez dans cet
entrepôt
je n'étais pas est ce qu'on comprend en
creux c'est qu'il ya au minimum une
défaillance de ceux qui étaient censés
vérifier physiquement l'état de ses
stocks
le patron de l'eprus à l'époque
l'établissement de préparation et de
réponse aux urgences sanitaires
une structure qui a perdu 40% de son
budget entre 2010 et 2015 14% de ses
personnels ensuite on a fondu l'eprus
dans cette agence santé publique france
sans augmenter ses moyens et elle est
peut être la clé de ces manquements à
face à des risques multiples il faut
bien arbitré quand on n'a pas d'argent
merci beaucoup géraldine bon il va l'eau
il ya un sujet sur l'état des masques
olivier véran être dit ici même que ces
masques ne les donnerai pas un lapin
nain pour reprendre son expression
qu'ils étaient moisi qu il fallait les
détours il n'était pas emballé quand
même fini soit élevé ce qui leur ont été
alloués aux cétacés voilà déjà la beauté
ont été laissés de côté ceux qui ont été
ceux qui ont été détruits n'ont pas été
distribués non non ce qui a été
distribué non non nous n'avions pas de
l'été c'était unique
ils ont été déclassés grand public jeu
yaya banana moi même j'ai une généalogie
de cette histoire des masques à à
établir parce que il ya un rendez vous
en 2011 qui dit ben voilà les masques
chirurgicaux destinés au grand public
des moeurs des masques d'état avec un
objectif d'un milliard les masques ffp2
dont je comprends mais ça je parle sous
contrôle des spécialistes que eux ont
une date de péremption ont besoin de
rouler plus rapidement donc ils sont
déconcentrés décentralisant les invitant
dans les hôpitaux et et dans les menant
dans les premières acquisitions ya pas
de normes européennes et il n'y a pas de
date de péremption 2014
apparaît une norme européenne qui
conduit à partir de 2016 à faire tester
ses stocks de masques et il se révèle
que en 2017 ou 2018 qu'ils sont quittés
le son qui sont non conformes au regard
de ces normes européennes et donc il est
décidé c'est en 2018 de détruire 600
millions de masques et 2 ne racheter que
50 millions
50 millions c'est les moyens le
permettent et c'est là où il ya une
vraie question c'est y lieu semblerait
qu'il y ait un changement de doctrine et
que un changement de doctrine en 2011 en
2013 et en 2000 en 2013 il semble pas y
en avoir une en 2018
il n'y a pas de reconstitution des
masques et de l'audition de monsieur
seulement je comprends il nous l'a dit
qui considère que l'absence de consensus
scientifique sur l'utilité des masques
le conduit à ne pas leur commander et là
la ministre madame du samedi j'en ai
jamais entendu parler et je moi je
considère que comme haut fonctionnaire
avec des responsabilités quand on prend
des décisions qui en prennent tous les
jours mes décisions aussi majeur et qui
sont un changement de doctrine
par ailleurs établi plusieurs années
avant dans un dialogue
interministérielle avec eux le
secrétariat général de défense nationale
c'est une décision dont la ministre
aurait dû être informée et qu'elle
aurait dû prendre on arrive sur la
question de qui savait quoi est ce que
c'est possible
les deux ministres marisol touraine et
roselyne bachelot très clairement
aujourd'hui design aux usa on doit
savoir on ne peut pas dire qu'on ne
savait pas ça n'est pas possible
nul n'est plus aveugle que celui qui ne
veut pas voir
c'est à dire que la sur l'histoire de
marisol touraine je suis désolé mais il
ya un moment donné qu est ce qui se
passe on nous dit j'arrive ya je sais
plus 750 millions je repars c'est à peu
près pareil formidable mais un million
qui marchent pas et on attend donc oui
il ya un changement de norme en fait
elles mêmes mais c'est la norme et on
attend et en attendant 2017
2010 est donc la fin du mandat pour
demander si ces 2016 à 2016 2012-2016
2016 monsieur valait donc dgs de monde
sur ses stocks détruit certains étaient
utilisables
alors est il demande une auditif est un
audit il regarde ce qui se passe pas que
sur les masques d'ailleurs sur toutes
les capacités de réponse à des épidémies
en france on a la réponse
dix-huit mois après bon accélérer le
fonctionnement mais je trouve que oui
oui c'est ça la question santé publique
france qui normalement dit
j'entretiens régulièrement je surveille
régulièrement mon stock il faut 18 mois
pour répondre
voilà je note est au bout de 18 mois on
nous dit il n'y a plus rien il ya 650
millions de masques qui ne sont pas aux
normes
il ya plus de piles diodes ya plus rien
voilà donc on peut dire qu'on avait des
stocks mais quand on sait qu'en fait une
fine et ses stocks qui n'était pas
valable
bon voilà dont acte je voudrais vous
faire réagir là-dessus on voit qu'on est
en train de reconstituer une chronologie
très techniques complexes pour essayer
de comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé dans
l'administration sanitaire et au niveau
du ministre sur sur un stock de masques
avec des doctrines qui change
comment vous regardez ces débats-là bon
la question que je me pose c'est si ces
masques avaient été présents en nombre à
une opulence de masse aurait changé la
manière dont aurait géré de l'épidémie
et je regarde un peu ce qui s'est passé
ailleurs dans le monde est ce qu'il ya
des pays qui ont une stratégie 100 %
basée sur le masque qui a évité un
confinement qui a évité les conséquences
économiques
non à l'évidence non c'est il ya aucun
pays même en asie
il n'y a pas eu de stratégie qui a été
basée sur le masque qu'il aurait évité
de passer par ce parcours on est passé
il ya quand même un port du masque était
plus développés au jeune fille née en
chine où ils sont confinés au japon
comme partout il ya plein de pays sont
pas confinés mais ils ont mis des
mesures de distanciation sociale et puis
ils ont tellement adhérents stop colussi
marché bien un jour là ils ont aussi une
application qui marche bien voilà il ya
rien qui a été communiquée d'une
stratégie 100% masques et je pense qu'en
france de toute façon c'était trop tard
on devait se confinait donc vous pouvez
pas voir une stratégie masque on s'est
rendu compte parce que l'épidémie s'est
probablement développé sur plusieurs
mois de manière tout à fait silencieuse
après il a commencé à voir des clusters
dans l'oise
on a fait ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
c'est à dire on a été isolé les clusters
on a en fait exactement la même chose
que ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
et puis après on a commencé à voir les
services qui se remplissait ça a été la
panique on a confiné à partir de man ont
été confinés jusqu'à la fin du
confinement il y avait plus de sujets je
crois concédé confiner les conditions
qui faisait qu'il y avait suffisamment
de masse donc une question à nouveau
parce que survienne chose qu'on comprend
pas c'est certes le confinement était
total sur l'ensemble du pays on a
l'impression que le virus a été écrasée
de manière presque plus importante que
ce que les
experts des scientifiques des médecins
imaginez ces de confinement total ça ou
sos que c'est l'incertitude qu'on a sur
ce vieux équipe qui fait qu'on comprend
pas tout à fait plein de punch à la
sorte et qui disent que c'est le
confinement qui a permis d'écraser et
puis le fait que tous les pays qui
seront relâchés au bout de trois quatre
semaines ça remonte comme des états unis
le fait qu'on vois qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à stopper l'épidémie parce qu'ils
arrivent à confiner que la moitié de la
population d'amérique du sud
le fait que même en chine où ils ont des
conditions drastiques et des clusters
qui sera précisée voilà on sait que
c'est le confinement qu'a joué on s'est
toutes les infections pendant
confinement c'était dans les familles
dans les foyers dont il est juste que
c'est bien vous parlez des états unis
parce que je voudrais qu'on retrouve
françois durpaire parce qu aux etats
unis
vous l'avez dit l'épidémie évidemment ne
s'atténue pas du tout au contraire
bonsoir françois donald trump refuse
toujours de porter de masque alors que
plusieurs régions américaines se sont re
confinés comme la floride où l'artisanat
donald trump est le seul chef d'état et
chefs de gouvernement à ne pas avoir
porter de masque pendant cette période
du coronavirus et il en a fait sa marque
de fabrique
on se souvient de cette image volée
c'était le 22 juin dernier dans une
usine ford dans le michigan images
volées parce que d'un train s'était mis
en colère en disant la presse américaine
me fait un sale coup je ne devais pas me
montrer avec se masser pour donald trump
une question de virilisme politique
alors il est seul et contre tous un
évidemment contre les démocrates mais
également contre ses propres équipes
vice président mike pence porte un
masque la première dame
on l'a vu avec un masque sur twitter a
les mêmes militante du masque et la
plupart de ses collaborateurs porte un
masque alors pourquoi cette attitude de
donald trump et bien c'est une manière
de faire du populisme sanitaire de dire
à ses électeurs je suis contre
l'establishment je suis contre la raison
médicale
je suis contre le devoir éthique et
moral tous les hommes politiques vous
disent de porter un masque mais moi je
suis au dessus alors la conséquence de
cela bien c'est qu'on personnalise la
tragédie du coronavirus et que l'on dise
c'est la faute de nha trang c'est un peu
ce qui s'était produit
george w bush en 2005 on parlait de
katrina de l'ouragan katrina comme le
désert de george deubeuliou bush
c'est ce qui est en train de se produire
pour donald trump et le coronavirus avec
une conséquence immédiate sur le plan
électoral moins 10 en moyenne de
sondages par rapport à joe biden il
faudrait maintenant un miracle pour que
puisse l'emporter
les précédents historiques c'est carter
qui était à moins 10 mai qui a perdu
c'est george bush père qui avait
également perdu il ya qu'un seul
précédent heureux c'est harry truman en
1948 qui était à moins 11 en juillet qui
précédait novembre de l'élection lui
avait gagné et évidemment donald trump
il va espérer reproduire l'exploit de
harry truman mars à me lâcher c'est le
contre exemple absolu les etats unis en
matière de gestion sanitaire
bah oui là là ça se passe pas bien pour
eux ils vont s'en sortir parce qu'ils
vont finir par confiner et puis vont
réussir à casser leurs courbes saaq
trump entre la chloroquine en préventif
ça c'est un vrai sujet est là pour le
coup je pense que c'est important parce
que leur est la répercussion mondiale de
cette histoire de pure routine elle a
été un trait impression que moi j'ai des
amis qui sont en amérique du sud
puisqu'il ya des gens qui prenaient de
la chloroquine et qui sortait sans
masque en se disant je suis protégé
alors qu'il avait aucune preuve là pour
moi ya un vrai sujet c'est à quel point
l'impact mondial de cette histoire de
chloroquine ou le vol aller ça a dépassé
un petit peu dire après le match
remporté 1 parce qu'à son âge s'ils
attrapent le corner les russes il va pas
se sentir bien donc je pense que moi je
prescrire et un masque pour lui maurice
bellot c'est vrai que l'annoncé ait deux
poids deux mesures total ça n'a rien à
voir mais c'est vrai qu'en comparaison
on se dit on est on est peut-être un peu
qu'on en ait un peu dur avec avec nos
gouvernants quand on voit ce qui se
passe aux états non mais je dis à
personne n'espère en france avoir un
zozo comme un peu comme président de la
république à ça je vous le confirme
eh ben on va voir il ne porte pas le
masque et barbry johnson je crois même
assez peu de précaution n'est pas rare
qu'à regretter amèrement
j'ai d'abord vite le mot de la fin cette
commission denquête elle est utile vous
aller vous allez faire voilà il va
déboucher une sorte de réformes
peut-être le système de l'administration
c'est un peu ce qui ressort en bas
finalement dû tourner il faut évidemment
screen et tout ce qui s'est passé mais à
écouter les experts c'est pas forcément
ça que je gêne on écoutait beaucoup
d'experts doutent quelques semaines ici
c'était tous à l'unisson une
problématique aussi entre agences donc
il faut aussi qu'on discute du
fonctionnement de ce qu'on a mis en
place nous en tant que élus est ce que
ça fonctionne est ce qu'il faut le
modifier et ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin
jean n'en parlais tout à l'heure dans la
santé publique voilà donc non bien sûr
qu'il y ait aimé y aura peut-être aussi
bien des étudiants palestiniens
l'aviation c'est uniquement de savoir si
c'est un tribunal et si il ya des
responsabilités à travailler aussi
peut-être le fait d'avancer et d'être
constructif et de trouver des solutions
pour la suite mais dernière fois soyons
toujours très modeste et très humble en
santé parce que c'est toujours très
difficile
c'est toujours beaucoup plus facile à
posteriori est d'ailleurs la prochaine
fois aura-t-on le même virus aux deux
choses pas qu'il prochaine fois mais
difficile
merci merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau de lcp pour ce débat on va
parler à présent d'airbus qui passe en
économie d'énergie si l'on peut dire la
restructuration du constructeur
aéronautique et massive 5000 postes
supprimés en france toulouse nantes
saint nazaire sont les sites français
les plus touchés 15000 dans le monde ont
fait le point avec ahmed tazir avant que
d'autres invités nous rejoignent sur ce
plateau
et voici que la pandémie continue de
faire payer un lourd tribut aux géants
de l'industrie et aux compagnies
aériennes
c'est le plus gros plan de réduction
d'effectifs de l'histoire d'airbus 15000
postes vont être supprimés en europe
dont 5000 en france et autant en
allemagne ce qui représente au total 11
% des salariés
le président du géant aéronautique parle
d'une crise d'une gravité incroyable
loose les syndicats s'opposent à tout
licenciement contraint
alors les lignes rouges de
l'organisation syndicale et sont très
claires pas de mesures de licenciement
contre c'est le combat ça va être au
complet dans toute la filière parce
qu'aujourd'hui
airbus fait ces annonces vous imaginez
que avec des mesures pareilles dans le
chef de file de la filière les
conséquences que ça va avoir dans les
prochains jours vraisemblablement pour
d'autres entreprises
le gouvernement veut minimiser l'impact
de la crise sur l'emploi et sur la
restructuration d'airbus
il espère sauver 2000 postes si vous
mettez en place l'activité partielle
longue durée qui a été annoncé et
qu'airbus va évidemment utiliser ses
1500 emplois qui seraient sauvés on
investit aussi massivement sur l'avion
de demain la nouvelle génération
d'avions verts sobre en carbone
ces 500 emplois qui vont être sauvés
pour un bus déjà 2000 emplois
l'avionneur a déjà bénéficier du chômage
partiel pendant la crise il profitera
également du plan de recherche du futur
et du nouveau dispositif de chômage
partiel de longue durée
la direction d'airbus devrait préciser
son plan ce jeudi bonsoir marc touati
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
économiste et vous êtes à la cdefi
rappelez moi ce pc c'est mon cabinet qui
s'appelle donc c'est bien aux commandes
de l'économie et de la finance
merci d'être là vous êtes journaliste de
la pardonnez moi alors je n'ai
d'habitude aider voilà c'est la
pardonnez moi journaliste à libération
spécialiste de l'aéronautique
monsieur le député cheilan berges et non
par deux fois absolument pas non mais
l'heure où je ne savais pas je n'avais
pas de lecture nikkei nogal pardonnez
moi je pense que je vais m'en désole
débuté la république en marche de
haute-garonne et le journaliste à
libération que vous êtes mais l'analogie
souffrir général et faux air france
pardonnez moi je jeûnais zone de temps
je n'ai pas ma petite note
je suis absolument désolé christophe mas
logis vous êtes syndicalistes et on va
commencer peut être par vous parce que
le sujet est extrêmement extrêmement
grave
est-ce que vous avez une idée entre
airbus et air france
avec les sous traitants de l'ampleur de
la saignée sociale qui se prépare
non j'aurais du mal à m'exprimer sur sur
airbus puisque j'ai pas les données
chiffrées sur air france les chiffres
officiels n'ont pas été encore présente
et ça le sera vendredi donc difficile de
les commenter aussi mais quoi qu'il
arrive le secteur du transport aérien au
regard des emplois de ce qui pèse dans
notre pays
ça va ça risque d'être un drame social
web concernant airbus on est sur à peu
près quinze mille 15 mille suppressions
de postes dans le monde 5000 en france
les sites les plus touchés est ce qu on
a une idée c'est toute l'occitanie cetc
la région de toulouse parce qu'avec les
sous traitants on arrive à combien c'est
au moins plusieurs centaines de milliers
de personnes
on n'est pas là encore je pense qu'il
faut pas disons que vous prendre la
mesure de l'ampleur des dégâts mais
qu'on a qui vont une récession mondiale
qui aujourd'hui est dramatique et donc
évidemment mais comme on est en plus sur
un discours un petit peu de
démondialisation
on n'a pas arrêté nous dire faut arrêter
de prendre l'avion et c'est donc sorte
de fectivement vol bashing entre
guillemets donc ce qui fait que on peut
pas à la fois dire bah nan faut arrêter
de prendre l'avion puis quand derrière
airbus ou air france licencie bas c'est
très grave
il faut qu'il faut éviter ces
licenciements donc c'est ça le vrai
enjeu c'est que on a une crise
historique pour le secteur de l'aérien
on a une baisse des chiffres sont
énormes c'est à dire que au niveau
mondial on aurait une baisse de près de
290 milliards de dollars 2 du chiffre
d'affaires du secteur aérien mondial -
85 milliards de dollars juste pour
l'europe c'est comme des chiffres qu'on
n'a jamais vus et puis surtout les
perspectives c'est que ça qui est
inquiétant
on ne sait pas comment on va réussir à
s'en sortir ce que demain va alors si on
a un emploi fortiori si on a une
deuxième vague est ce que le tourisme va
redémarrer ce que traille d'affaires va
redémarrer
tout ça pour l'instant n'est pas garanti
donc c'est ce qui fait qu effectivement
vous l'avait bien dit on a déjà des
premières phases du licenciement qui
vont malheureusement s'aggraver et bien
sûr des airs vous aurez les sous
traitants qui vont également payer la
facture sur l'ampleur francky quand même
parce que n'oublions pas une chose il
n'y a plus que deux constructeurs
d'avions en ce bas monde
airbus et boeing il y en a qui s'appelle
boeing qui avait déjà de réels problèmes
avant même que la crise sanitaire ne
débute
et airbus a un carnet de commandes avec
à peu près dix ans de livraisons devant
lui donc on peut comprendre
qu'effectivement et nous on l'a constaté
à libération il ya des avions qui ne
sont pas pris par les compagnies
aériennes qui les ont commandé néanmoins
qu'airbus refuse de nous dire
aujourd'hui c'est pas faute de leur
avoir demandé c'est quel est le niveau
véritable des annulations qu'ils ont dû
enregistrer qui justifierait les quinze
mille suppressions d'emplois qui sont
annoncés oui donc confort de ses clients
pour vous il ya quoi une forme de de
doute sur sur la nécessité d'aller aussi
loin dans les suppressions de postes il
ya un doute qui touche airbus mais qui
touche l'ensemble de l'industrie et nous
posons la question régulièrement
libération qui est de dire est ce qu'à
un moment donné les plans sociaux qui
sont annoncés certes répondre en partie
à la crise économique que nous vivons
mais ne sont pas également une
opportunité pour faire des réductions de
coûts qui vont passer de manière un
petit peu plus douce on va dire
malheureusement sous la coupe de la
crise sanitaire mais qu'elles ne gagnent
que peu gouvernement on sait qu'il ya
des plans de soutien massifs 7 milliards
pour air france
l'état est actionnaire vous allez quoi
vous allez rejoindre rallonger rallonger
les aides ou
il ya une forme d'impuissance des
pouvoirs publics dans cette situation
d'abord je veux dire que si aujourd'hui
les annonces de guillaume faurie et de
la possible suppression de 15000 emplois
en europe et 5000 en france inquiète
si l'état n'avait pas été au rendez vous
on paraît pas de 5000 emplois menacés en
france mais bien plus donc je crois que
il ya aucune entreprise et et j'ai
changé en compte 6 1 j'ai encore
échanger ultra des économies mais dit je
crois que personne n'a à coeur de
supprimer des emplois est ce que les
gouvernements l'état accompagne
accompagné pendant la crise il faut il
faut avoir en tête que 98 % du trafic
aérien était complètement arrêté non
mais c'est un monde comme ça a été dit
là où tout le monde fait ce constat
sa reprise est très lente un arrêt
complet donc la construction des avions
qui s'arrête au déchaînement les ennemis
aux etats unis en australie en chine
personne n'est capable de dire ici
comment l'épidémie
du coup vite va évoluer donc évidemment
on est tributaire de sa donc l'état doit
être au rendez vous ce sera le cas avec
un dispositif d'activité partielle
longue durée qui en cours d'élaboration
et justement en lien avec avec les
syndicats il y aura peut-être des
départs anticipés mais toujours sur la
base du volontariat en tout cas ce que
l'on dit avec le gouvernement les
parlementaires et ont rejoint la
préoccupation des syndicats c'est qu'il
faut éviter tout licenciement sec et
tout départ contre east of may logis sur
cette question là au fond du calcul
stratégique
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
cette crise elle cache pas d'autres
licenciements qui ne doivent pas tout il
ya plusieurs sujets à des sujets
conjoncturelle à savoir la crise donc
combien de temps va durer comment
combien de temps mettra pour retrouver
une activité équivalente à 2019
certaines 10,2 en trois ans cinq ans
s'étend donc en fait on n'a pas
exactement les chiffres et qu'on les
multi sera dans la maîtrise raja mais il
ya aussi du structurel et les compagnies
low cost avait commencé bien avant nos à
faire beaucoup d'économies sur les coûts
quitte à faire du dumping social et
fiscal est aujourd'hui les compagnies
legacy comme lufthansa ou les groupes
comme ing ont annoncé d'énormes
suppressions d'emplois avec des baisses
de salaires aux moules la solution de
l'activité partielle doit se négocier
dans les entreprises pour permettre déjà
sur le conjoncturel de passer les deux
années qui arrivent parce que rien ne
sera résolu
à ce stade vous vous refusez déjà les
5000 suppressions de poste vous êtes
évidemment en négociation mais c'est
alors chez air france c'est ma
souffrance que mais en tous les cas quel
que soit le nombre de suppressions
d'emplois nous on veut déjà faire
l'analyse de ce qui est structurelle et
conjoncturelle de pouvoir regarder si la
stratégie aussi fonctionne parce que
cette perte d'emploi sont liées à une
stratégie est derrière faut s'assurer
que air france + contiennent mis six ans
air france samedi
je corrige marc touati ya eu des erreurs
stratégiques quand même airbus là je
parle d'airbus non moi je chante avec
eric et l'a380 la exemple il est cheikh
de l'a380 effectivement mais bon comme
l'a dit un sens c'est que cinq airbus
est une compagnie exceptionnel c'est à
dire c'est un fleuron européen français
bien sûr mais également européens ne
faut quand même pas l'oublier c'est 135
mille salariés
ouais ça veut dire donc c'est tombé sur
ces 10 % au total c'est c'est énorme
mais c'est quand même je dirais une
entreprise qui va pas comme ça
s'effondre et donc malheureusement on a
une réalité qui est sans précédent
donc c'est sûr qu'il faut réagir lent il
ya eu déjà des annulations alors on ne
sait pas effectivement combien dans le
détail
moi je pense qu'un ajustement beaucoup
plus mais qui ne veulent pas justement
affolé notamment les investisseurs mais
le prénom je sais qu'il faut bien
prendre conscience que le boeing
justement a déjà malheureusement
licenciés 16 mai seize mille personnes
et pour revenir sur les compagnies
aériennes parce qu'effectivement là
aussi on l'a évoqué c'est pas qu air
france c'est pas un mal français parce
que là on a travaillé ce que l'on
pourrait penser que c'est uniquement la
peine à cri le mans en france
encore une fois on y va on a aidé
effectivement nos entreprises alors
peut-être pas assez ça qui est aussi un
secteur du tourisme qui est massacrée
parce que c'est un peu ça hein pourquoi
aujourd'hui on a moins d'avions
commandés parce que les compagnies
aériennes vol - alors bien sûr il est
low cost notamment il le touati elle
vole moins provisoirement et puis oui on
peut s'arrêter au ca belleu business
model je termine de business model
effectivement des low cost aujourd'hui
risque je dirais de disparaître donc
c'est ce qui fait que malheureusement
beaucoup de compagnies vont annuler des
commandes
elle me regardait levant plus reporter
calculer des grosses bourdes et monsieur
nos gardes auraient quand même pu vous
poser une question également
l'état français a mis 2 milliards sur la
table pour aider les compagnies
aériennes à décaler leurs échéances pour
acheter des airbus
les tamis 600 millions d'euros sur la
table pour acheter des hélicoptères pour
l'art b en anticipation de façon à
garnir un petit peu les finances les
finances d'airbus
est ce que l'état français finalement
vous représenter quelque part qui est
actionnaire d'airbus à hauteur de 10%
n'auraient pas pu dire finalement pour
des techniciens dans la construction
aéronautique qui sera hautement
qualifiés c'est un vrai dommage pour les
entreprises que de les licencier
maintenant quand on en aura peut-être
besoin dans deux ans dans trois ans et
qui fera de nouveau reformer des
compagnons et prendre du temps et de
l'argent pour les mettre à niveau alors
qu'on aurait pu les garder c'est
justement pour aller dans votre sens
c'est justement le principe de
l'activité partielle longue durée c'est
quoi c'est quoi le chômage partiel
longue durée c'est préserver les
compétences et les emplois on sait que
il va y avoir un creux pour les raisons
qu'on ait évoqué tout à l'heure on veut
préserver ses compétences à la fois chez
airbus et aussi chez les sous traitants
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on fait
l'activité partielle c'est aussi pour ça
que l'état prend en charge une part
supplémentaire de l'apprentissage parce
qu'on ne veut pas qu'il ya un creux
générationnel dans l'ingénierie et dans
les dom et sincère limité la casse sur
exercice dont on peut reprendre le plan
aéronautique de 15 milliards il ya
évidemment 7 milliards axé sur air
france avec dp jeux et des prêts des
prêts d'état vous avez là on est en
train d'examiner à l'assemblée nationale
le pen fr3 le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif numéro 3 avec des budgets
en amande un abondement de budget sur la
robotisation avec 100 millions dès cette
année 200 millions 2021 et 2022
on augmente le budget en recherche et
développement et en arrêter 1,5 milliard
il faut que les français se rendent
compte aujourd'hui en recherche pour
2020 ce qui était prévu comme budget
c'était 135 millions on aura un point 5
milliards sur trois ans signalé par
exemple il est très bon ingénieur est
connue exergue l on voit aussi que le
fleuron justement de l'innovation
technologique est ce qu'on vous craignez
pas que voilà avec le rebond s'est
peut-être l'économie ce qui va nous lie
avec le rebond de cette activité elle
finira par partir
on se prive de ses ressources humaines
le sourire des gens l'objectif de tout
le monde se regardait les emplois c'est
dire que je pense que justement la fef
est un vrai sujet parce qu on a vu après
les élections dernièrement on parle
beaucoup de décroissance parce que les
rangs dédaignant il faut décroître pour
baisser le niveau de pib de richesses
etc
mais là on voit ce que ça coûte la
décroissance quand vous avez une
activité qui s'effondre ben vous
détruisez des emplois derrière des
entreprises qui disparaissent c'est ça
qu'on vous met effectivement en temps et
je termine effectivement le vrai enjeu
il est là c'est que ce que vous avez dit
c'est que le la dynamique moi je pense
pas qu'il faut tabler sur sur la reprise
parce qu elle sera molle malheureusement
cette reprise
il faut tabler justement sur de
l'innovation et que le seul moyen de
faire de la croissance durable dans un
monde fini c'est en optimisant
l'existant au travers du progrès
technique progrès technologique et donc
il faudrait qu aujourd'hui effectivement
ce pour airbus
on arrive on parle de l'avion à
hydrogène ou autre mais qu'on arrive
justement c'est pas normal quand j'ai la
voiture électrique a fabriqué à parler
de musique c'est ça le franc je sais que
il faut qu'aujourd'hui
non nous ayons sur l'aviation sur
l'airbus bas un nouveau moyen
effectivement et que sans savoir qu'il
faut 30 ans à peu près autant développer
un avion 31 mai une vingtaine d'années
et puis comme vous avez la mémoire de
l'économie dans vos fonctions vous vous
souvenez quand même que après le 11
septembre 2001 où les avions se sont
arrêtés deux volets après la crise
financière en 2008 où les avions sont
arrêtés de voler quelques mois quelques
années après le trafic aérien mondial
ares continue c'est une erreur d'analysé
que des banques c'est comme ça ça n'a
rien à voir là pour le mode c'est un des
points de compétences comment voyez vous
dire c'est plus l'emploi que l'économie
c'est qu'en fait on se retrouvait des
avions qui sont cloués au sol avec des
compagnies qui vont chercher investir si
elles ont la trésorerie pour le faire
dans des nouvelles technologies des
avions plus économes en kérosène
par contre les avions qui sont au sol
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait les vieilles les
vieux avions en fait en france on n'a
pas de deux usines pour pour démonter
ses avions et peut-être que le
savoir-faire qu'on a de construire des
avions peut être utilisé pour les
déconstruire les démons je partage
totalement gérant d'une contribution à
bruno le maire et jean baptiste djebbari
sur ce sujet je vais proposer justement
qu'on développe cette filière
industrielle du démantèlement on a
aujourd'hui des acteurs tels que tarnac
qui à tarbes fond du démantèlement je
pense qu'on va avoir besoin d'augmenter
d'augmenter les volumes parce qu'en
effet de plus en plus d'avions vont
sortir des flottes et j'ai même aussi
proposé ça c'est un sujet qui doit être
discuté au niveau européen mais une
prime à la casse européennes pour
justement accélérer la sortie des avions
les plus polluants et puis essayer de
relancer la machine relancer les
commandes pour faire vivre toute cette
filière est sûr c'est que les prix vont
sûrement augmenter d'un mot le billet à
10 euros jean baptisé barils à dia dit
c'était donc tout le business model du
low cost aujourd'hui effectivement il
est battu en brèche je voulais justement
sur le sais c'est pas la même crise
qu'en 2008 2 ou même en dominant ses
pions c'est dramatique aussi soutient
changement de paradigme mais c'était une
crise en 2008 financière en 2001 bondir
plus terroristes là le problème qu'on a
c'est moi j'ai pris l'avion dernièrement
donc vous avez le masque vous avez les
hôtesses emmitouflés que ces dames c'est
à dire ça donne pas envie de voyager ou
est ce que veut dire donc si on doit
faire des vols de 10 heures comme ça
c'est clair que tout le business model
je dirais de l'aviation de tourisme
également d'affaires et là aussi est
battu en brèche donc c'est là où ce site
tant qu'on n'a pas un vaccin une
thérapie qu'on peut pas enlever enlevé
snow masque pour reprendre l'avion c'est
quand même un vrai problème pour les
vols long courriers notamment et donc se
dire que le le modèle même de l'aérien
est en danger donc c'est pour ça qu'on
peut pas pourra pas redémarrer commencer
ou ici même ont déposé une proposition
de loi françois ruffin delphine batho
hier pour faire des permis quotas
carbone de deux voyages en avion qu'ils
soient de l'aérien est en danger dit
marc touati et on a parallèlement de
ceux de l'autre côté de la planète à
dire en asie une nouvelle population une
nouvelle classe moyenne asiatiques qui
ne rêve que d'une seule chose c'est de
découvrir ce vaste monde qui fait
qu'airbus à installer des usines en asie
même à tianjin et qui fait que demain
après demain
cette nouvelle classe qui accède au
transport aérien va voyager malgré tout
y compris avec un masque et remplira
donc les avions
mais comme vous le savez aujourd'hui les
frontières sont fermées donc la chine c4
cc a et un seul c'est 30 quand 40% de la
croissance mondiale et notamment un peu
plus dans le secteur aérien donc c'est
effectivement et chinoises éthique vous
l'avait bien dit c'est sûr que c'est là
la croissance de demain
s'ils ne sont pas là ou si on on réduit
effectivement on continue de fermer les
frontières c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
eh ben ils vont ils vont pas voyager
même s'ils ont moins et le mot de la fin
on sent que la ligne de crête est alors
vu ses exigences écologiques et la
reprise à terme s'est installé aux états
unis un bus est installée en chine et
produisent pour ses différents marchés
si on prend la famille a320 elle est
fabriquée entre toulouse et hambourg
aujourd'hui le mas c'est le le la force
de travail j'allais dire les usines et
sites de production qui sont menacés sur
le territoire européen
c'est ça et c'est l'état s'engage et
encore une fois le plan de 15 milliards
sur un plan majeur
l'allemagne soutient le faire dans un
délai donné le plan de 15 milliards
c'est d'abord 7 milliards de prêts
garantis donc ça que je les y ai moi
même tout à l'heure et est ce que vous
pouvez venir les budgets notamment pour
la recherche appliquée tout à l'heure il
a réduit oui mais un milliard et demi
c'est 10% de 15 milliards l'activité
celle longue durée tout ça ça coûte des
milliards et vous inquiétez pas l'etat
sera au rendez vous merci messieurs on
est au début de cette crise
elle va durer et vous aurez compris que
vous aurez serez amené à en reparler et
toutes mes excuses avait compris que
j'avais un petit problème de
d'impression de partage c'est l'ère de
la chronique thomas des prêts ma journée
à l'assemblée
nous parlions hier des bons résultats
des écologistes aux élections
municipales
et bien ce soir thomas nous explique que
ces élections n'ont pas fini d'impacter
le fonctionnement de l'assemblée n'est
ce pas thomas exactement myriam et
ces élections municipales ont également
pour conséquence de nous priver de
certains députés devenue mère et qui
vont devoir quitter l'assemblée
je vous raconte tout ça alors sur la
ligne de départ ils étaient 63 députés
candidat tête de liste à ces élections
municipales ce week end
22 ont été élues et 20 ont donc décidé
de quitter l'assemblée nationale le
palais bourbon où il avait été élu en
2017 et qu'ils vont donc devoir
abandonner préférant leur mandat de
maire bonjour j'ai lurton jours alors
vous vous allez quitter l'assemblée
nationale je vais quitter l'assemblée
nationale la fin du mois de juillet avec
beaucoup de regrets mais ça veut dire
que l'assemblée nationale ça ne vous
intéressait plus j'adorerais mais vous
savez il ya des conditions politiques
qui font que parfois et bien il ya des
opportunités qui se présentent et puis
parfois la population vous pousse un
petit peu aussi c'est ce qui s'est passé
à saint malo ont tous un peu poussé à
faire une liste pour ces élections
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que le mandat de député aujourd'hui il
n'attire plus ça veut dire tout
simplement que peut-être on aurait dû
mieux réfléchir sur le cumul des mandats
je pense qu'ils avaient frappé les
français c'est le cumul des indemnités
et si on avait fait une loi en disant
n'y a pas de cumul d'indemnités
mais un député qui veut être maire ou un
maire qui souhaite être député il pourra
le faire mais et se réserve que le cumul
n'existe pas je pense que l'appréciation
roja aurait été différent il ya près de
soixante députés qu'ils sont présentés
en tête de liste aux élections
municipales ça veut dire que le mandat
de député il n'intéresse plus pour ce
qui me concerne j'avais une passion pour
cette assemblée nationale j ai fait
adopter une loi jeudi dernier j'aimais
beaucoup ça mais vous savez la vie
politique les fêtes de sarry un moment
où on a voilà on a besoin de vous un
autre poste et j'ai pris mes
responsabilités je les assume
lorsqu'un député kit l'assemblée il est
normalement remplacé donc par son
suppléant ou mais voilà selon nos
informations cinq des suppléants des
députés élus ce week-end ne veulent pas
devenir député de nouvelles élections
vont donc devoir être organisées dans
les circonscriptions
nous on a voulu savoir pourquoi ce
mandat de député ne faisait pas rêver
ces cinq suppléants là il faut être un
peu fêlé 1 pour accepter d'être député
aujourd'hui il ya un antiparlementarisme
qui est quand même extraordinaire on est
un parlement un peu malmené même la
majorité
se trouvent parfois le doigt sur la
couture est un peu malmené alors
imaginez dans l'opposition on a parfois
le sentiment de regarder les trains
passer et ne pas pouvoir le prendre le
train parce que vous êtes minoritaires
parce que vos amendements ne passe pas
vous pouvez passer des dizaines d'heures
à bosser pour cinq minutes en séance à
défendre un truc super chute qui fera
flop parce que la majorité vous dis flop
voilà mejia vont suivre à l'arrivée de
ces suppléants nouveaux députés à la
rentrée pour savoir ce qu'ils pensent de
leur mandat parlementaire
mais ça on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
dans ma journée à l'assemblée est ainsi
s'achève cette émission merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve demain pour
un nouveau ça vous regarde très belle
soirée sur lcp
[Musique]